there's an interesting article in Vice
suggesting the idea of testing
presidential candidates for cognitive
decline executive function is a term it
sounds like we're talking about CEOs but
what we mean by executive function it's
a term that is a collection of cognitive
processes necessary to control behavior
so very simply it's things like
attention span inhibition people should
be inhibited to different degrees
depending on the situation in which they
find themselves memory cognitive
flexibility each of these has a specific
scientific meaning there are more and
more questions about Donald Trump's
cognitive decline a 73 year old man
there are questions being raised about
Joe Biden that have come up a 76 year
old man there have actually not been any
serious questions about Bernie Sanders
cognitive state he's 78 years old but
there is a lot of disagreement about
this because there are those who react
and say this is an ageist idea I don't
believe that it is ageist in the sense
that there are a high percentage of
people as they approach 80 years old
science tells us this who have some
level of reduced cognitive abilities now
I happen to believe that there are also
significant advantages to being more
experienced and having lived more time
on this planet to being president and
there are areas in fact in which
problem-solving with a more less
judgmental more flexible sort of
approach is present in older folks and
it is not present in younger folks and
there are all sorts of arguments that
can be made but given the science around
it it doesn't seem crazy to me
particularly given the behavior of
Donald Trump that we might say maybe all
candidates should be tested for a
cognitive decline or you know when it
comes to driver's licenses people start
having vision tests and having to be
retested only beyond a certain age some
might say 65 or whatever the case may be
now I know there will be people who
watch this clip or listen to me talking
here and they'll say David Trump was
screened he got the Montreal cognitive
assessment and he's fine now this is
nonsense
the Montreal cognitive assessment is a
one page thirty point test the
screens for very specific and very
serious cognitive decline sometimes
connected to stroke or to certain types
of dementia it is completely unsuited
for really figuring out if someone is
fit to be President temper mentally and
cognitively in all of these things the
Montreal cognitive assessment tests
visual visual spatial visual abilities
including for example saying draw hands
on a paper on an on a drawing clock for
what it looks like when it's 230 draw a
3-dimensional cube you get six of the
thirty points on the Montreal cognitive
assessment just by saying it is a you
know it is March 5th and I'm taking the
test in Boston Massachusetts for example
I know it's not March 6th I know it's
actually June 10th so this is not a test
that truly can tell us whether one's
behavior at a more nuanced level one's
inhibitions once met one's memory etc is
suitable to be President of the United
States but this is merely about taking
seriously the concerns that anyone who's
been paying attention should have about
what's happening with Donald Trump and
arguably with Joe Biden there are some
questions as well of forgetting Barack
Obama's name and we've had other
examples of this there are again this is
not ages there are many ways in which
older folks are better thinkers than
younger people approaching problem
solving in broader ways there's there's
a list of them there are nevertheless
groups like AARP insisting that this is
not something that should be the focus
period but the president has proven it
should be a focus there is confusion
there is self-contradiction trumps
visibly confused often he has errors in
judgment he's spatially confused coming
off of Air Force One his limos right in
front he starts wandering away and has
to be pulled back by Secret Service on
and on and on he wants to see the
oranges of an investigation we have the
ability to test for this stuff it is not
beyond human scope to test for this
stuff the test that Donald Trump took
the Montreal cognitive assessment cannot
do it it's too low a threshold if he was
impaired due to stroke or in other ways
the Montreal cognitive assessment might
show it it would not show what it is
that Trump appears to be suffering from
but good luck getting candidates to
choose to opt into this type of testing
the only way it might be made Universal
is if it's made mandatory and that is
extraordinarily difficult legally
because the Constitution lays out very
specifically they are simple in basic
guidelines citizen and 35 37 years old I
don't even remember I always get
confused between 35 and 37 years old I
guess 35 but it is extraordinarily
difficult from a legal perspective to
add new requirements or change the
requirements to be President of the
United States so let me know what you
think there's really two questions do
you believe this is something that
should be done to all some candidates
based on age or no candidates at all and
if you do believe it's something that
should be done what is the mechanism
through which it should be done should
it be demanded as something that
candidates should merely accept sort of
like most candidates up release their
tax returns and financial disclosures
should we try to codify it into election
law should it be done at the state level
sometimes it's believed that states have
more flexibility in terms of imposing
additional requirements like requiring
tax returns to be released to be on the
ballot as we are seeing let me know what
you think I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on twitter at david pakman show
and make sure that you're following me
on twitch at twitch.tv slash david
pakman livestreams upcoming this week on
twitch I want to tell you about one of
our sponsors called the Menlo Club a
men's fashion community that provides
carefully curated style packages for any
type of guy and they're giving you as a
David Pakman show viewer your first box
for $35 off when you click the link
underneath this video or go to their
site and use the promo code Pakman as a
member of the Menlo Club you receive
delivered right to your door a
hand-picked apparel package that follows
the seasons latest trends based on your
own unique style profile I hate shopping
for clothes it's always been a pain to
go to a store figure out what to buy and
that
why the Menlo Club is so perfect for me
all I had to do was fill out a quiz on
their website so they could learn my
sizes and style preferences and then I
received clothes that perfectly fit my
own personal style so far I've really
enjoyed what they've sent me all of
their clothing is designed by their team
in Los Angeles
each box features items from their own
in-house fashion brands five for
everyday wear New Republic Footwear and
Grande see athleisure wear in every box
they send you you get a minimum of two
items often more every box is different
shipping is always free and they let you
exchange what you get if it doesn't fit
you can pause or cancel your
subscription at any time right now I am
on their monthly subscription for 60
bucks a month but they also offer a
seasonal subscription where they send
you a box of clothing every three months
for just 75 bucks but regardless of
which option you choose they are giving
everyone in our audience $35 off their
first box to redeem your $35 discount
just click the link under this video or
go to their website and use the promo
code Pakman at checkout